ولكن من وجهة نظر إستراتيجية ،
ما مدى أهمية عودة الشعر
إلى الأيدي الأوكرانية ،
فمن المهم من منظور معنوي
للقوات المسلحة الأوكرانية
أن الكتابة كانت على الحائط
بالنسبة لتلك المجموعة الروسية من القوات في
الضفة الغربية للنهر منذ حوالي  في يوليو
أو أغسطس ، كان موقفًا لا يمكن الدفاع عنه
بالنسبة لهم لعقد الأوكرانيين قد
هاجموا معظم الجسور المتعددة حتى
يتمكنوا من إدخال الإمدادات وإخراجها ، لذلك
كان لروسيا في بعض النواحي خياران
رهيبان قبل أن تبقى ويتم تطويقها
وهو ما كان من الممكن أن يكون
كارثة أو
القرار السياسي المحرج بضرورة التراجع عن
السيطرة ،
تحدث عن
أهمية موقع هاريسون على وجه التحديد
حيث يقع بالقرب من شبه جزيرة القرم
لكل من الروس والأوكرانيين
، وهناك مشكلتان قيد اللعب الآن بعد أن
أخلت روسيا من تلك المنطقة
يشير بشكل أساسي إلى نهاية
طموحاتهم للسيطرة على معظم
ساحل أوكرانيا في البحر الأسود وثانيًا  الآن
ما تستعد روسيا للقيام به هو إنشاء
خنادق دفاعية على
الجانب الشرقي من النهر للدفاع عن
نفسها في شبه جزيرة القرم من هجمات Highmar
أو التقدم الأوكراني المستمر.
لقد أجرت روسيا ذلك
لأنك إذا قارنته بما رأيناه
سابقًا ، أعتقد أنه حدث في سبتمبر
بعد ذلك الهجوم المضاد المفاجئ في
الشمال الشرقي من قبل الأوكرانيين حيث
رأينا الروس يتراجعون من لومان
فقد فقدوا الكثير من معداتهم العسكرية
ناهيك عن
ذخائرهم وجنودهم في ذلك أه
ما ترونه هنا
أرى شيئين مختلفين لذلك مع
ذلك في مفتاح السيارة الذي يمكن
وصفه بدقة على أنه طريق
ضغطت القوات الأوكرانية على
الوحدات الروسية التي كانت تحت قوتها وليس
وحدات الاستعداد الأعلى بشكل خاص
وعندما واجهوا الأوكرانيين في
المواقف القتالية ، فروا ببساطة
كان ذلك بمثابة تراجع مذعور الذي تخلوا عنه  ذخائر
المعدات
لقد كان حقًا
نوعًا من الذعر من حالة الخروج ، أود أن
أقارن ذلك بما يحدث أو ما
تم التوصل إليه مؤخرًا في خاركيف
وهو شيء تم التحكم فيه من قبل الوحدات التي
كانت تتراجع إلى
المواضع المعدة مسبقًا كانوا يفعلون ذلك ببطء  بمرور
الوقت ، أعتقد أن الأمر كان قيد التنفيذ
لمدة ثلاثة أو أربعة أسابيع على الأقل ، لذا
فهو تراجع ، لكنك لم ترَ هذه
المعارك الواسعة النطاق التي لم ترَ
خسارة هائلة للجنود الروس ،
لم يكن ذلك انسحابًا مذعورًا  لقد
كانت متسرعة لكنها لم تصب بالذعر